[Music]
my name is will torres i'm one of the
admission officers at the stanford
graduate school of business and we're so
happy you're here to join us
today we are joined by theo of our
alumni whose stories i
can't wait to hear and can't wait to
share space with
um as we get started i also definitely
want to recognize the incredible tragic
tragedy in lebanon and hope that
you are either able to contribute or
do something by way to help our brothers
and sisters out there
in their road to recovery
so to our panelists so we are going to
start
left to right so jonathan will be
starting with you if you can say your
name
where in the world you are and if your
favorite learning experience uh
at the gsb and that could be either a
class a
outside extracurricular experience or
the learning itself
cool uh hi everyone uh so i am jonathan
avida
um broadcasting live from
omer israel um the southern part of
israel
um so for my favorite
um experience at the gsb
i think um it's a close call between
two one is which i'm her i'm sure
you'll hear a lot of which is touchy
feely
um and i'm sure we'll talk about uh that
later on in this uh
in this call um it's a very
very powerful experience um
and i think my top one
is um leading the global study trip
to israel um which is just a phenomenal
experience in in many ways
one is just you know leading the global
study trip and
you know as an mba too uh taking a group
of mba ones
and um
[Music]
you know trying basically what
i think makes what made it a
particularly
powerful experience for me is um
it made me for the first time
try to uh look at my country
at israel from the eyes of
uh foreigner um and you know so if like
trying to uh i don't know
explain uh explain my country uh
to other people and of course you know
meeting with
all the you know political leadership
and business leadership of the country
uh is just uh amazing yeah jonathan can
you tell me a little bit more was there
a specific
focus of the trip like was there like an
entrepreneurship focus or another
dimension that you're really interested
in
yeah i mean so um israel
is known as the startup nation um so yes
that was definitely
the focus uh we met you know the
business leaders that i uh that i
mentioned um were for the most part
uh or almost all of them were around you
know entrepreneurship so either
ceos of very successful
startups or you know companies that are
even
no longer eligible for the startup
moniker
and vcs um
and yeah that was definitely the
definitely the focus of our trip
was the whole uh startup ecosystem
in israel nice thank you
ruchi yeah hi everyone i'm so excited to
be here thank you so much will for
inviting
because i'm dr uchidana i i was born and
raised in the middle east i was born in
libya that's in north africa and then
our family moved to dubai
when the libyan sanctions happened so i
did part of my schooling from libya part
of it from dubai and then i went to
medical college in india
and during my medical college days i was
working a lot on
low cost medical devices i was really
excited about like doing some
innovations in that space
but like i was the first student of my
university to get travel grants and go
abroad present papers and all but like
that time like the startup ecosystem in
india hadn't developed very well
and i really was fascinated by the
stanford biodesign course at stanford so
like the reason for choosing stanford
again was mainly because of the stanford
biodesign course so
like after my medical college days i
actually went to stanford for my
full-time mba
so my favorite class would definitely be
the stanford biodesign course because
a lot of innovative stuff comes out of
that and i'm really excited about
like the the innovations that keep
happening at the intersection of various
discipline
so what happens at the stanford by
design course is that there are doctors
engineers
lawyers phd students mba students
everybody comes together to solve for
unmet clinical needs
and our team actually won the nih grant
from the us government for needs finding
and
and then i led a trip to china on behalf
of that so apart from my full-time mba i
also got the pmp
degree so that's that's something that
stanford offers like if you
like complete certain course
requirements and there's a
a practicum requirement as well so that
fulfilled as per practicum requirement
and
i'm still in the medical device field
i'm currently working on a low-cost
robotic surgery startup and i'm
really excited to be here thank you the
uh trip to china was
kind of on the heels of some of your the
things that you were creating
yeah so so i actually traveled thrice uh
during my stanford days so one was a
trip uh
like an external trip that you have to
take so that was to japan so i really
love that so
like my senior class actually led that
trip so jonathan's class would have
led that trip and then i i led one trip
to china that was on behalf of the
stanford biodesign course
and then like in the second year i led a
trip to india
and on behalf of like our class so that
was the
the the practicum requirement for like
it's it's it's completely optional but
like i i love to do that and
and it was really exciting to lead that
trip to india and meet various
leaders and see various cultural sites
as well and
and that's when like you you lead a trip
and then like
the class next to you like the junior
class would actually be there
so recently i met the recent class
that's
that had come here to dubai for one of
their trips and it was really good to
meet the the students of the current
class
oh that's awesome i love when our alumni
are able to
continue connecting and and seeing our
students just in
like in person like it's amazing
cool
hi everyone this is ahmed from cairo um
hi so darling from cairo favorite two
experiences are
uh taking a class with irv grazbeck
conversations and management uh he has a
couple of videos on youtube so highly
recommend checking those out
and then a couple of dinners with like
classmates where we just talk about
raising capital
building companies uh those really help
kind of push
our thinking and imagination and i think
the last experience that really stands
out
is uh going uh on a trip to europe
to especially london and berlin to see
the startup uh
ecosystem there and meet with the top
entrepreneurs and investors
um it kind of really helps you relate to
how the actual building process happens
and
what needs to happen for you to kind of
build a company uh one day um after
stanford i came back to the middle east
now working with mckinsey um
so so anyone's thinking about making
that shift happy to talk a bit more
meanwhile i'm gonna go ahead and start
with a question for
the group very open-ended um many of you
are now working back kind of in the
mena region what was that journey like
where did
did you find career support how did you
find
kind of your current position
right i can i can go um
so one thing i uh meant
to say sorry i was thinking about it
ahead of time which
is uh true and i think says a lot uh
i think except for actually
the job that i'm in now that my four
previous job post usb were
all of them every single one uh i got it
through the stanford network um in
one way or another um so i think
it you know it really is a very very
powerful thing
um yeah and so specifically
uh in terms of um
moving back to israel um
which which i did that about two and a
half years ago after
eight years in the bay area um
then it was um
the connection was through someone uh
that i worked with previously
and then richie i know you have also a
global kind of trajectory can you tell
us
a little bit about like how you found
like maybe your job after
like immediately after the gsb and then
kind of
how has that shaped your trajectory
yeah yeah sure so i i was
i really love the stanford biodesign
program and now there are many such
programs that are coming across in
in the us and in other countries even in
india but like that was like the pioneer
program so
i have been involved with the program
and the faculty for very long
and even currently like the low cost
robotic surgery startup that i'm working
on it
actually came out of the program like
the team was uh
was there so that's really exciting and
we already filed two patents i'm one of
the inventors of that so that
goes back to the to my passion of like
working on medical devices and all
so like the gsb community has been
really supportive and
and the best part was that since like i
i was very open in in terms of
networking and meeting
people from other like schools as well
like the med school and all
so that actually helped me in quite a
number of ways because even
startup like oftentimes you need to get
support in terms of like data gathering
or things like that and you need
support of professors and like different
faculty members
as well so so that has been really
helpful because like the stanford name
itself
it opens up a lot of the doors but it's
it's important to also like
be present in the moment and network
quite a lot because
then it's then it's the best part that
you can actually gather all the
resources that you need to
make your life success nice
um amanda you were there
in at the gsb most recently of the group
there's a question
here in the box how did palo alto feed
into your overall experience
since you have some of the most recent
vision of it can you tell us a little
bit about that and
and then how did you go from palo alto
back to cairo
yeah sure so uh
first of all paolo also lets you uh ride
bicycles more often than you would
normally
so that that's an amazing part uh and
then
there's the fact that a lot of the top
if you're someone who's interested in
tech or innovation
a lot of the top venture capital firms
uh technology companies are based
either out of palo alto or maybe 13
minutes away
so you can literally go visit any of
these companies
and build those connections for yourself
so even when i was thinking about
you know coming back and and potentially
building something i met a couple of
investors
uh in in san francisco and then someone
in palo alto
who kind of made a commitment that they
would invest in a startup that i would
build
uh if i would do something back home and
that just gives you a lot of confidence
even if you don't necessarily go down
that path
and then how did you go from palo alto
back to cairo
did you have like yeah alumni network
career management center
it was it was partly career management
center and then when i was interviewing
for mckinsey the partner
uh was a gsb alumni
and she met her husband in the gsb as
well and so
so so so so i think that helped build
some
uh rapport nice there's a question here
ruchi already started to talk a little
bit about it
so the question from abdullah is
what advice do you have for
international students joining the
program
and like how do they maximize the
benefit of the opportunity
and ruchi mentioned kind of networking
beyond
the gsb at the med school um anything
else or from the other panelists
what other tips might you have for for
international students thinking about
coming to the gsb
yeah i think networking is really key
and apart from that like
i think i took my studies a bit too
seriously at
the gsp because i i came from from a
medical background so i thought like it
would be really intensive and all
i remember once i cut short my hawaii
trip just just to
study a bit and all but now that i think
back i think
like networking and like
mingling with people that's that's
really much more important because
like i still like i'm very much in touch
with the
the people that i met in the gsb we
communicate very often these days we're
having like zoom calls and all as well
and like it's it's a very tight-knit
community and and i think
my only suggestion would be just to make
sure to
uh like build those relationships when
you're there because it's just a period
of two years and then like
but those relationships would last for a
long time
and for international students i would
like to say like as uh
like uh abdullah was saying that in palo
alto there are like various companies
out there that actually are uh blooming
and and
all of that is happening but now that we
realize that many of these companies are
actually opening up their offices in the
middle east as well
so i'm in dubai and then there's google
facebook linkedin amazon every
everything has come now to the middle
east as well so it's important to have
those links
internationally at the jsp but like you
can definitely find opportunities in the
middle east
yourself as well because like the best
of the tech companies are now coming
to various countries in the middle east
as well so that
brings about like a whole new angle to
things because earlier on in in when
when we were there at
uh like coming back to the middle east
was a big question and all but nowadays
it's much
much the same similar decision because
you have all these tech companies
already existing in the meaner region
nice any other tips for international
students thinking about
coming to the gsb how to maximize
experience
yeah i mean um
sorry go ahead go ahead sorry
thank you um so i mean i think
this my experiences has been that this
is
mostly obvious for people but for all
the international students
uh coming to stanford ball state anyway
um
and and that is to um
[Music]
escape your comfort zone a little bit
this is generally true
at the gsbn and sometimes in life but
what i mean by that
is it's easiest uh you know to be around
you know like
really so um still you know to this day
my closest friends are uh
mostly the other israeli classmates um
but i made it a point i think all of us
made it a point to like
not just you know not just be a group
right like where we're not just like
okay a group of
is like no you want experience
if you want to experience
you know if you want to get the full
experience then
then basically
try to talk to people from uh
you know like other international
students and of course
uh all the americans and build strong
relationships there i think that's
that's absolutely key
um i agree 100 uh with richie and
jonathan
the one small thing i would add is uh
also
coming in with some form of like idea of
what you're looking for what you want
because
there's so many resources people from
all over the world
literally any path that you want to take
there are a lot of resources that can
help you
achieve the objectives that you have in
that path and so just
going in with the hypothesis of what you
want uh i think can really help you
focus your time
uh and also just get to know the people
that you know are
are more uh uh closely linked to your
interests and passions
uh uh study do the classes that are also
linked to your passion etc
so that would be my small addition nice
so kind of you mentioned like having
that north star
sometimes as you shoot for that star
that journey will also like
shift a little bit has anybody here um
gone through like career changes or
pivots
um and how might the gsb have either
helped
or informed some of those changes that
you've made in your
in your career
yeah i can i can go about it because
like i came from a very traditional
background of like
as a medical doctor and and like even
making a decision of going for an mba
was something really big for me because
like
as a doctor you have a clear set path of
like practicing and all of that
so it was a big change for me and one
thing that that changed even further
after going to the gsp was that like
suddenly i got interested into startups
before that i would think
like this is something that i can never
do it's so difficult i don't know what
what tech
problems people are solving and all of
that but once you go there you see like
at every coffee shop at every place like
you you see people
like sitting and discussing like new
ideas of like changing the world and all
of that and then
you get really excited so i got
introduced to the startup world
just because of uh like my background in
stanford and i still am so much in touch
with the startups and
and like making a few investments and
well and that's really exciting because
like otherwise
my mind would have been like much more
narrower i would have stuck to a much
more traditional field but like
going to the gsp it completely changed
my perspective what things like
anything is possible and these are the
people who are making the changes so
definitely there's something that you
can do as well
i can also say um
so my experience was um
[Music]
i was exposed to so much that i didn't
know existed before i came to the gsp
right so before the gsp i was i was an
engineer
um i knew i was interested in in
startups
but i you know i knew vaguely that there
was such a thing called consulting
and you know investment banking but i
had no idea what these things mean
um and so during the two years at the
gsp
you know for my internships and then
later for my full-time position
post-gsb i looked at
so many different things so many
different things
there are some people who are sort of
like laser focused like they know
exactly what they want to do
i was the exact opposite of that and
what is
uh nice what is good about the gsp is
um with all of
my classmates through my classmates i
was able to learn
about what are these things like what
does it actually like what is
management consulting really like
almost anything um so so i think that
was
um you know just a tremendous help
um and interestingly at the end uh what
i wound up doing
post gsp is exactly what i wrote in the
career essay
which is again like not it's not that i
was laser focused i looked at everything
under the sun
but i ended up doing exactly what i
thought ahead of time that i would do
it's just interesting
okay there's a question here about
the alumni alumni communities in some of
the different countries you've
you've been in and or currently are in
um can you talk a little bit about some
of the uh your the alumni groups where
you're at
like how have they shaped kind of your
experience post gsb
yeah i can speak about dubai we have a
very good
alumni network here in dubai especially
because like all of these tech companies
have also come here a lot of new talent
is coming
to dubai and abu dhabi so we have like
get togethers very often and now like
recently we were planning one get
together with the saudi community as
well
and the asian community as well so we
were planning a big uh
uh trip here to russell and like
they have the longest zip line there so
you're planning to do that but then just
go what happened so that got cancelled
but like
so this would have been like the first
like in my history it would have been
the first uh
alumni gathering from various countries
as well like
so because there are people coming in
from india people coming from saudi and
other
gcc countries as well but in dubai abu
dhabi itself we have a lot of meetups we
have some meetups with
other schools as well and there there
are some meetups that are specific just
for the gsb community
and like most in most of these alumni
networks you have like not just the gsp
community but the stanford undergrad
students and all as well because and
there are a number of those
here as well and those actually add a
lot to the experience
because they they can like we all relive
the days that we spent at the gsb and at
stanford and that
that becomes really exciting here
uh here in israel i'd say okay so
the israeli community both in israel and
in the bay area
are are pretty tight-knit so you know
many years the
um you know was in the bay area post usb
um it's a very uh tight-knit community
uh with a lot of like you know pre-covet
in person
like in-person meetings um
and like you know real personal
relationships
um and here
in israel my experience uh you know have
less experience
with the uh alumni community here in
israel but it's it's sort of like um
i feel like it's actually now picking up
speed
uh like there's more and more uh
things going on now
awesome great all right and so
this question is directed towards ruchi
from one of our attendees can you speak
towards your experience at the gsb as a
woman
um any clubs organizations other
opportunities
for women at the gsb
yeah there are a lot of clubs and and
opportunities for women i think like
diversity and inclusion is an import
important theme that stanford is
focusing on and i just has focused on in
the past as well
i remember like there were a lot of like
get-togethers that was distracted just
just for when and and even in in terms
of like
different tracks that women took so like
women and we see women in like medicine
and also
there were different those tracks as
well in which like you could just
network and and
find out and even stay in touch for
later on like even currently i'm in
touch with the woman and we see
community and like
we we post like jobs and deal flows and
various other things so that
that becomes an important aspect of of
life as well and
i think it stands for like it's one of
the most liberal schools and
and and it focuses quite a lot on
diversity and inclusion and
that's the best part and and like even
in terms of like the the accommodation
and all everything is uh
so flexible and you get to see like
a lot of collaborations happening within
within the various
communities as well within within
stanford yeah
nice thank you and then this question is
gonna be posted a larger group
feel free to take a moment or two to
think about it
so what was the biggest challenge so i'm
gonna adapt it just a little bit this is
the question
as asked is what's the biggest challenge
you face to get into stanford
um the admissions side as amazing as you
are you'll you'll never really know
kind of uh that element of it but i
think
another angle to this question could be
what was one of the biggest challenges
you faced
at the gsb and like how did you work
through that
um kind of coming back to the idea that
the experience can take so many
different directions like
what was the challenge that you faced um
and then how did you navigate your way
through that what resources or
support networks did you tap into
yeah i think i think initially when i
went to the gsb like we had a lot of
like close-knit circle of the indian
people and i sort of related
with them so so that was good but i
realized
very quickly that they were all
engineers and coming from the iits and
all and i was getting a lot
overwhelmed with the kind of uh like
courses that they were taking because
like even in the first year they are
they're like the
the basic advanced and the various
disciplines that you can take in each of
the courses
so i i try to take the most advanced
courses
and all then i realized that it's taking
up a lot of my time and i'm not
being able to spend a lot of time with
like quality time with my friends and
all
so i realized that it's it's it's okay
to actually take a normal track and
think about like your priorities in
life so i think that's that's a mistake
that i made early on that i
i was like like because i was thinking
so much about stanford and what i would
do there like i was like
okay everybody's taking this i should go
for this track but i realized later on
that it's
like it was taking up a lot of my time
in terms of like putting in the hard
work so i realized that i should have
taken like
uh much more soft skill courses or other
things that would actually have matter
much in life
thank you
wilk is it okay if i uh you know so i am
not an admissions officer i have no idea
how
decisions are made but can i try to not
give people advice
[Music]
challenging in the admission and i will
also answer your question is that okay
yeah i'd love that
okay um so one thing that
i found challenging in in the admission
process and i think
um again without really knowing uh how
things work but sort of
my impression that sort of like it's
something that
you need to do uh is to uh
so once the way you needed what uh what
i try to do what was difficult
is to um really
you know have the application represent
who i
am uh so it's not just like okay
this is look at my grades look what i
did now it's like
um my goal was to get to a place
where um if i let
my my wife read it or if i let my my
parents read it then they will know
that it's you know from from the essays
from the story like
this is me you know it's like not oh
this is uh
okay wow this this sounds like an
amazing person like no this is this is
you
um so that that was challenging uh for
me but it was
it was a great exercise in itself uh to
you know like the whole what matters to
you most and why to like really think
about it is
is a great exercise um says one
um two uh will's version of the question
um one thing that was challenging for me
i talked about a little bit
was um uh
landing a job post gsb um
so you know a lot of people
um basically um they
sign on for their
[Music]
full-time job like in in february i
did not have a job lined up even
graduation which was very stressful
um how but
uh what was helpful is again the the gsb
community we had like uh we
uh put together uh a group of people who
were all in the same situation and we
basically
all kind of like coached each other and
helped each other
and it was great so like it would have
been
uh very very unpleasant
to go through it by myself uh it's
a little bit unpleasant but drastically
less unpleasant
because of the strong support from from
within the class
i agree with that 100 uh i think
jonathan explained it very well i wanted
just to answer both parts
the the most challenging thing applying
to the gsb
was the most rewarding one which is
answering the question of what matters
was most few and why it was very
difficult because
i also wanted it to be kind of genuine
authentic um
so i took some time spent time with my
family and
close friends to get to the answer that
i don't come through with
but when i arrived at that answer i was
like wow
yes this is i have so much clarity on
what is important to me and
kind of what i want to do in the future
so that's the first part on the second
part
uh one of the most difficult challenges
is i feel like
just my impression is that the gsb can
be it's a very high support culture but
also high expectations
in some way and so uh between peers
you might find some i would say a little
bit of expectation of pressure
to go in certain directions so some
people are building companies other
people are going through
tech companies roles other people are
into consulting et cetera
i was the only i think the only person
who returned to the middle east so that
was very challenging
uh uh just making that decision um
because it went a little bit against the
flow of you know
uh find a good company in silicon valley
and work for uh so so i would just say
uh uh you know try and find something
that you really care about you're really
passionate about and
um the way i dealt with this was to find
a support system
as a group of close friends who really
trusted my
thinking and kind of helped me walk
through that decision
thank you we do have a question here
about work experience so while there is
no
work experience requirement to apply and
be admitted to the gsb
the question is about how that work
experience
might either inform or affect
kind of how much you're getting out of
the program um
can you talk a little bit about did you
have
like what were you doing before so on
the slide we had a little bit about your
your pre-gsb industry so
maybe a little bit of what were you
doing before the gsbn how did that shape
um kind of what you got out of the
experience like
did that really impact um your the
outcomes from your experience
yeah for for me it really helped me
because like uh
because of the work experience i had i
could understand much more about the
courses at the gsb
and just be much more uh like
be able to participate even more in the
lectures because like how the
classes work is that like there are
number of questions that are thrown at
you and you have to like
give your perspectives as well so like
when the case studies happen it
it's ad it adds a lot of value if you
have some sort of work experience and
you learn quite a lot from
your classmates work experience as well
because they have interesting stories to
share during the case studies
so i think the work experience for me
definitely helped quite a lot i was
working in the healthcare industry i
knew like i wanted to like
do something in terms of like the
business development of
of healthcare and but but i didn't
really understand the language of
business i didn't understand anything
about business so
so it really helped for me like to get
that exposure early on that this is the
need the clear need that i want to solve
when once i'm at gsp and i was really i
learned
quite a lot from like the experiences
that my colleagues shared
during the case studies during the
lectures itself so i think
work experience add to that adds a lot
to that aspect as well like you learn
quite a lot from your classmates as well
uh yeah so
um pretty much
yeah i agree 100 with everything that
ushi said um
basically it's the the i think a
way to look at it is
the class is sort of like a tapestry
of like a bunch of
very very different
backgrounds and all of the all of those
um you know basically they're brought up
in in class and outside of class and so
um you know my work experience uh so i
was
uh an engineer pre-gsp and before that i
served
in the idf um so you know i felt like
you know i had something to contribute
in terms of talking about tech
in terms of talking about leadership
somewhat
um but i knew nothing absolutely nothing
about the the world of business so first
of all
you know stuff like in terms of
what you hope to get out of the gsp it's
different for everybody based on their
background like for me
like all the uh core curriculum was
great like i i was really interested
for me to learn finance and um
operations and organizational behavior
and all that stuff um
and econ like those things
were interesting for other people
[Music]
who come from background
uh that might be less interesting but
other things will be more interesting to
them so
um i think it's it's uh like i was
saying before you know
be clear on on you know what what it is
that you
want to to get out of it and and when
when you're at stanford let go you know
stay true to that and and and push for
that
uh there's like so many um
there's um all the student clubs
uh which i'm sure we'll probably uh get
asked about
there's just like uh so many things that
you
can get out of your gsp experience
it's up to you to sort of like be clever
about
uh your path
since you brought up clubs um there are
a couple clubs like i'd love for you
the group to chat more about i know uh
ahmad you were
one of the co-presidents for one of our
regional interest clubs can you tell us
a little bit more about that
yeah sure uh so so
you know i think uh we talked a little
bit earlier jonathan richie will about
you know the importance of community etc
um and and regional interest clubs is
just one way to build the community
um and so i think in my experience um i
i was co-leading
the the middle east club and helped also
launch
the first um middle east stanford forum
um to help bring together people who
really cared about the region and just
want to
you know discuss important topics um and
it was a really rewarding way of
you know uh getting to know people
who shared interests but to be very
honest with building friends
uh so a lot of these people we just some
of them we have like weekly or bi-weekly
calls
uh and when i was talking earlier about
the support
group this is a big part of where it
comes from you know people who really
understand your culture
have a similar background interests and
so they can kind of help
guide your decision-making uh uh when
you eat things by the future
and also i think one just small part uh
there's an important part of the club
industry like the professional
networking all that stuff is the
cultural element so
for example in uh uh ramadan we
organized
uh iftars for the entire class
uh you know some of our
uh classmates organized trips um so
there's an important part of culture
that helps you feel
that you really belong to this place
so so that's a part of it as well
sorry i have uh a couple of things that
i
i i'd love to share about clubs
um so one maybe is
uh the mina club uh so
um you know it is uh
it is no secret to anyone probably in
the skull or anybody in the world right
like the the middle east you know
it's it's a tricky place and and israel
and the rest of the middle
east it's a complicated relationship to
say the least
um but um in the mena club
uh i was able to participate in
you know conversations with classmates
that i
don't know any other
sort of like place in the world like any
sort of scenario where i
where i'd be able to be in in such
conversations were
you know that was uh you know very
powerful experience
and and and you know one sort of like
one
center of that um i remember uh
as an nba one at the beginning of the
the first year at the gsb um
we had a meeting of the mina club in uh
one of the nba two's house and we were
watching
uh an israeli film um about
uh it's called uh dancing with bashir
it's it's an
israeli sort of like war movie
um that's sort of like not in my opinion
like not pro-israeli not anti-zoo is
basically an anti-war
and we were watching this movie three
israelis
uh two saudis one person
or two people from egypt one person from
iran
and i remember like to me that was a
real experience
uh but it just goes uh
like i it's good to show like what a
special place
uh the gsb is and how special the
student clubs can be to allow you know
such such an experience to happen
yeah just just just adding on to
jonathan's point actually
so i'm i'm uh indian but i was
born and raised in the middle east and i
was actually the leader of mina club
there
so i was the cfo of meena club and it
was like everybody is so receptive to
such things and and they allow you
and it's almost like a big family so i
was leading
like the meena club we organized a
number of get togethers we invited a
number of guest speakers so like the
head of aramco had come to
stanford and that was really exciting so
so you get all of these opportunities
it's up to you to like
take what what you really want to do
because like there are ton of
opportunities to lead
to uh like uh participate in various
events like this
number of brown bag lunches that happen
like almost every day when you have a
guest speaker coming in and you can just
go in and participate
as also like part of the leadership team
of south asia club
so so that that was another aspect but
like i could relate much more to the
amina club because i was born and raised
in this region so
so that was really exciting and like the
best part was that
everybody was so receptive of like like
their elections that happen when you
lead a club and also that that was
really good i loved it yeah
nice and so as we start to wind
down for the event um i want to make
sure that we get there's like a couple
of
themes here in the question box about
tips
um things that maybe you would tell
yourself so
take a moment and think if you can give
younger you a piece of advice
what would that advice be
that's a tough question i'm happy i'm
answering last
yeah for for me i think it it was mainly
about like
i was taking myself so so seriously and
as like
uh one of the most students studious
students in my
medical college as well so i think like
i went with that mindset and when i went
at stanford and i realized there are no
board exams because the education system
here
everywhere else is completely different
that than there so like
when when i realized there are no board
exams it's like there's
no great disclosure and also that that
was a relief
so i would say like um to not take
myself so
so seriously in the very beginning and
to end too much more
relax and mingle more with the community
that i think that that would be
the one advice i would give myself
yeah i think that i resonate a lot with
what richie said um
i think one of the most special things
about stanford is its people
and here i'm i'm referring to
classmates alumni and professors uh
so i think earlier on i was very shy to
like reach out to professors and
have lunches or dinners with them i was
also very shy to reach out to a lot of
classmates
and now i'm actually friends with a lot
of them i
co-invest with some classmates so
if there's any small thing i would just
spend a bit more time getting to know
the different people whether it's the
professors
uh the classmates the the alumni um
and just not waste any opportunity if
you find this connection with someone
uh in the stanford community
i think the advice i would give myself
is yeah it's very similar
to and i mean i i
did do a lot of that but basically
um
to get to know as many
of my classmates as possible
in depth like to really get to know them
you know
because in the gsp it's
something that we talk about a lot like
um because it's a relatively cloud
small class then um everyone
knows almost everyone uh but there's
knowing somebody and
there's really knowing somebody so like
i i
would give myself the advice to like get
to really really know
as many people as possible
wonderful thank you so much for that so
right now i do want to thank
our panelists so much for your time it
is an incredible honor to be able to
share the space and hear about your
journeys
and i can't wait to see where it goes
next so once again
thank you so much everybody for
attending thank you to
our panelists and with that we wish you
a great rest of the evening
rest of the day and a great weekend
ahead wherever in the world you are
thank you and um hopefully we'll see you
again soon
[Music]
you